this thing's a little moldy
it's uh it's lovely though very nice
thank you
yeah
where's the coffin
good
two years you know things just slip out
of your mind so I get it
I mean
two years that's longer than we did the
uh whole Venus on it
it's actually weird if you think about
it it's been three years
since the idea first was born
the world
[Music]
yeah
I mean
the one year anniversary of the death
felt like it was just yesterday that it
had ended now yeah I get what you're
saying it's distant it's faded like it's
faded really quickly
which is fine like that that's what
happens dude it always does fade you
know things just kind of did
but
um I mean no
I I doubt it is for you either
because what it is is all of those
lessons and all the learnings and all
the things that came up about it and the
stress and the joy and the pain like
those just became part of me
I Incorporated all those things and
carried it on at the work that I did
maybe not to the same degree of
uh relentlessness that Renaissance was
but you know
I definitely learned a lot
foreign
mm-hmm
and in a weird way like with living in
the moment it's both appreciating it for
the moment and also realizing that a lot
of the moments in between don't matter
which can sound scary and I get it like
it may seem counter to the message to be
like oh every moment matters but it's
like there's a lot of moments in between
that don't matter that are still really
really important
like time's gonna tick by no matter what
they can't all be incredibly important
seconds
I don't know I just I just really love
those
calm ones
you know
the moments in between the moments after
like an upload just went up
and there's a little bit of rest before
it's like okay get the content engine
going again
yeah
that's nice
least alone in a time when the world was
incredibly alone for a little bit there
yeah I get that it's funny I've I've
worked on a few things
since with other people but it was never
the same you know it's always with
um a lot of people who it's their job to
work on the project and not that there's
anything wrong with that people have to
have a job
um and thankfully I've I've been able to
work with people that were almost as
passionate about the idea as I was and
that's a lot to expect out of someone
who you just met for the job I've also
had the opposite you know a lot of
people that were on these just for jobs
you know they they didn't have any
passion for it and I I find that so
curious you know I would I would be so
passionate about something I'd fight for
something and they they no one would
fight back for what they believed in
because they they didn't believe in it
and they didn't see the feeling of it
and they didn't see the potential of it
and it's like
five I I kind of felt bad that either
through you know being jaded or just not
having the opportunity to really embrace
the the joy of of making things and the
joy of like
what who dishonest was in a temporary
nature of it and the potential you know
like a lot of people out there just miss
out on it even if it's gone and you have
to let go of this idea
there's more out there
oh yeah yeah
yeah
and it's like of course there's never
going to be another when it's honest
there's not going to be two in this
honest as much as people joke about it
like it's just it couldn't happen if you
understand what it's about you know why
it couldn't happen
but at the same time I don't think that
the idea itself
is going to be gone forever I think that
I would hope that someone else could
make something that they're just
passionate about that they have the
right circumstances for it that they
have the right talents for to to just
make something for the sake of ending it
you know there's I think
I don't think that we as much as it is
cool to have like a YouTube Legend I
don't think that we're some exceptional
unbelievable god-like creators maybe we
are who knows time will tell but like
we're just
[Music]
a few people that like making things you
know that's it
that's what it's all about
um
yeah
now it's it's uh it's a show of feelings
you know it's a the whole channel was
just based around the feeling
not a lot of people get that and a lot
of people can get that you know there's
this concept that
uh human thought is not necessarily in
words even though if we think in words
we think that's how it is but we're just
thinking in words of the things that
we're taught to translate our feelings
into and reality feelings and emotions
are the fundamental human language in
making things with feelings in mind
Woods should seem natural and yet is so
counter-intuitive and especially the
darker feelings you know the feelings of
loss and Nostalgia and
um
pain and and things ending you know
people don't like to embrace those
feelings but there's there's Beauty in
in those feelings because there's Beauty
in like The Human Experience and that is
uh to quote Lion King You Know The
Circle of Life uh it is it's just
ah man I ever tell you I'm super
profound in the way I talk and uh I say
words real good you know
um
um
it's it's a difficult question to answer
because sadness is not necessarily
the same
it's it's not a
simple emotion right
because you can Cry tears of joy you can
uh
you can have extreme pain at happy end
you know sad memories
for me I'm never really sad about it
I'm really not uh that may seem strange
to people but then again you know it's
part of part of the channel That was
trying to rip people's hearts out
intentionally
um but no I I I don't get set I do
feel very strongly you know
the same feelings is when it was
starting and ending
I resonate with those but I wouldn't
call it sadness
whether or not I miss it is a different
thing I would not equate that to sadness
but of course yeah
I miss it
I miss those moments I miss the
the grind of videos and it's oh we can
never do it again
we could never make videos again ever
the biggest tragedy of them all
um
Ethan I won't take you back yeah look we
can't do anything
what's in the past is in the past
no uh I get that you kind of and again
don't take this wrong way you kind of do
these videos and you you record it and
you're like all right cool then you ask
yourself well what was the point of
making that you know what was the
meaning behind it other than just making
content which is fine it entertains and
it's fun
but if you have seen like a glimpse of
what real real meaning is in something
you kind of look for it everywhere
you look for it everywhere and if you
want to find meaning
I got you a present
yeah if you look under your chair
there's uh
you got her pops
are they melted
okay good
okay
good
good
you wanna just see some Otter Pops
yeah
so we recorded multiple it was probably
brick soccer
great idea
you know kick a brick for around for a
while you do that when you step away and
be like Oh yeah this is gonna make
people feel something
I mean that was the whole thing really
didn't matter what the videos were
that's kind of
there will be someone that dissects this
all with better words than we ever could
in the true meaning of it but the thing
is people feel it you don't necessarily
need to translate it sometimes you do
for the people that weren't there to
understand it but for those that were
like they get
mm-hmm
yeah
it is nice
they'll they'll be less and less people
every year but
yeah for those that it had meaning it
really really had meaning
it's beautiful that people are willing
to share you know I know we joked about
it at first just being like whoa
redacted or whatever and people really
took that up uh not in the way that I
was intending I never
never wanted people to forget about it
or pretend it never happened
I think people did I think actually I
just realized right now that is what
people did
to
compensate for the pain of it being gone
you lean into humor and you lean into
like inside jokes
because it really did hurt
a lot of people it hurt real bad so for
some it might have been easier just to
deny
and feed into that joke
man
but it did
that's what matters
mm-hmm
mm-hmm
you know it's a an even sadder thought
though
is if we were to do this every year
which who knows maybe we will
if we were
up come a year
someday
or one of these chairs will be empty
and then
both
probably because one of us will be
canceled like let's just be honest so
let's just be perfectly honest with each
other here I'm not talking dead
if we're faffing about about doing this
honest in 20 years God help
foreign
[Laughter]
pumps
yeah
I don't know what you got fast prize all
right
sweet
nah don't throw the scissors I got
what was that Amy
don't throw the scissors I think maybe
you should well I don't don't do it
is he gonna do it
okay good
maybe you want our pop
Amy doesn't want an underpop
come on Amy
don't leave me another Bob
she caught it
but I did
which one of us is going to die first
I hope so too
man you suck
um
oh no we didn't have OtterBox yeah
memories
all right see you then next year
okay
oh my God